my guest tonight is the author of the
new york times best-selling
rad women's series her latest book is
called rad american history a to z
she's also a fierce advocate for social
justice who's shedding light on
racism feminism politics and the
responsibilities of white people
in the world today as if wow i think
that covers everything i don't think we
need to do an interview now please
welcome
kate scott hi kate hi hi conan hi
thank you for being here and let me
explain
our our trajectory uh to anyone who may
not know
um right after uh the killing of george
floyd we had
two weeks of discussions on my show
trying to just open it up talk to a lot
of different people one of the first
people i talked to
uh was w kamau bell who's uh
a a friend of mine over the years a guy
i know and
and trust and i thought let's let's have
this conversation and one of the first
things he did in his interview was said
conan
i'm going to assign you
what was the word he used a whiteness
counselor
i think so i think he said that i was
going to be in charge of your whiteness
in charge of my whiteness and um first
of all
i thought i pity whoever's in charge of
my whiteness because
that is a lot of whiteness to be in
charge of
so much blinding yeah and then i thought
um
i got confused because i thought well
wait is this person you're assigning me
to
if she's there to help me be more white
it's not necessary but apparently that's
that's not what it was all about
and we have started up a bit of a
dialogue you and i
and i've been looking through your books
and i'm very impressed
but tell me when uh
when our mutual friend said whiteness
counselor or you're in charge of my
whiteness how did you interpret that
and uh so i interpreted that as you know
it's it was kind of an
offshoot of a conversation that came out
and i had had um you know earlier that
week so
in the in the wake of the murder of
george floyd and the
uprising around racial justice that we
saw and experienced and are still
experiencing
come out texted me and said you know
basically he was like hey all these
rich powerful white people with tons of
privilege keep asking me what do i do
uh and he was like i don't know what to
tell them can i send them to you is
there like a website you all have
like for white people like what what do
i do with them and i wrote them back and
i was like yes send them my way
come out of course like you don't need
to deal with that right now i did not
expect the first person uh for him to
stand my way to be you
yes it happened immediately and it's the
worst news you ever got
you know it was great and and you know
but what i really saw
was was an opportunity to do what i
think i've always tried to do which is
you know leverage my platform and my
privilege to
make some kind of impact um whether it's
through books or through
uh teaching which i did for many years
or through just having conversations so
i
thought well i've got a lot of new
followers on twitter and on instagram
um and i really believe that in this
particular moment
white people have a lot of questions and
and
they deserve to be able to ask them um
they're all great questions no but
there's a lot of confusion and there
there it was and is still a lot of what
do i do what's the most effective thing
to do what's happening
um those questions don't need to be
directed necessarily to
your black friends and colleagues and
neighbors um so i was like well i'll
just get on
instagram and ask people to send me
their questions and we'll just start
talking
and i got hundreds of questions i still
do
um and i've been doing my best to answer
them um
honestly so many people
and i'm going to include myself who
feel like oh my god i don't want to make
a mistake
i want to be an ally i want to
move the piece forward i want to
be the solution and not part of the
problem
but i'm terrified of making a mistake
and that leads to
i think a paralysis that is not helping
can you speak to that a little bit
yeah you know i i like kind of using the
term you know uh
co-conspirators or accomplices uh rather
than allies you know
those folks are the people who've made
mistakes uh
and who've heard the feedback
learned and kept going right um that
that paralysis
is it's you know it's really really i
think actually
really selfish um and and incredibly
unhelpful you will
so the question isn't what do i do if i
say the wrong thing
it's what when i do this or say the
wrong thing
what's the best way for me to respond in
that moment you know we're all gonna
mess up and it's not just around race
men are gonna say the wrong thing to
women we're gonna misgender people we're
all you know we
are gonna do and say the wrong thing and
cause someone harm
so often in a way that we're absolutely
not meaning to and that's so often what
people say is well
that wasn't my intention like i didn't
mean that
that wasn't my intention what if but
it's something that you do or say harm
someone uh
and and they let you know that what you
need to be able to do is listen to them
and hear them
and understand how you can do better the
next time you know if and if we just let
that paralysis
uh you know take over and we just don't
say anything uh
you know that's that's that's part of
the large systemic problem
we have the um obviously a lot of people
talking about
uh the book uh white fragility which i
believe was written about a year or two
ago but
you know immediately became uh this
that this uh very sought after book
after the killing of george floyd and
and people talking about well discussing
what's in there what i found was really
interesting
was in that book there's
addressing this idea that
um white people have so much
fear and sensitivity about race that
we're afraid to make a mistake and then
you think about it you think well
a faux pas is a small price to pay for
trying to engage
meaning if the price that i'm going to
have to pay
to educate myself and to
grow and evolve is to be embarrassed
a bunch of times that is less than the
size of an
atom compared to the himalayan mountains
which are
hundreds of years of racial
discrimination so get over it
i think i encourage people to think of
well what's the worst thing that can
happen
right if you if you put on a black lives
matter t-shirt or you put a sign in your
window
or you take the step to bring something
up to a family member
and that's like you know might might be
uncomfortable or awkward or even really
contentious
what's the worst thing that can happen
and what are you willing to risk for
something that you believe
um you know and i think that what i want
to encourage people to do
is if you know is to get clear on your
beliefs if you believe
uh that we have a history of systemic
racism in this country
if you believe that black and brown
people are disproportionately mistreated
by police
uh if you believe these things if you
believe that black lives matter
then you know what are you willing to
risk to talk about that and to share
that message with people in your
community
in some ways very simple and yet clearly
we talk about there's the paralysis and
fear
that we see in this country about people
worried to make a mistake and then the
flip side what i want to ask you about
is defensiveness it's a very simple
thing to go i don't know
maybe i did maybe i did make a mistake
maybe i was biased maybe maybe
how could i not be biased let's talk
about it
it's such a simple thing to do but but
people put up this defensive wall
and it's that defensiveness i think is
the hardest thing to get over
it is and you know to what i like to you
know i kind of like to turn it around
and say like
what exactly are you defending no can
you get that upset
um because we've had this conversation
and it's that's the thing it's not just
about
getting accused of doing something that
is seen as racist you know
people will be furious that you and i
are actually having this conversation
um you know so for those people it's
like what what are you so upset about
how is this harming you what exactly are
you defending
um are you just defending white
supremacy are you defending
um you know uh that that position um
yeah it's it's the defensiveness is huge
and i i you know i really appreciate
um you know you i appreciate you having
me on and i appreciate you being willing
to have this conversation
after the fact right because i think
that in all these conversations that we
have about
what white people can be doing and be
better and all this stuff i think
accountability
and follow-up is a huge part of it right
so we can have these conversations in
the weeks after these horrific things
happen
but then we kind of go back to normal
right yeah i
i was gonna show um like i don't have it
as a
but i was gonna hold up my phone and say
we are very much
uh a society that's like what are we
talking about now
so uh right now it's trump's getting
impeached
and that's all anybody wants to talk
about and then
we move on and then it's covid and then
we move on
and then george floyd is killed and
uh everybody says this is now what we're
going to talk about
and you think this is fantastic and it's
not that people are
consciously saying
dismissing it as an issue but then kovit
resurges and we move on
and then that is i think the issue is
so much good or dialogue so much good
dialogue
and so much raw emotion was vented
in the last two months
that you think let's
a sort of a path has been opened i don't
think we've ever seen sustained
anger and concern like that in my
lifetime um
i'm 28. yeah you're a lot younger than
me so
yeah yeah i just it's sun damage um
but we haven't seen this
and yeah this is a an opportunity to
keep the path open and keep exploring
so you're right i mean i i do think it's
essential to
not say well check we did racism
yeah right we pulled down a bunch of
statues and
um i think we're good let's move on
because
we haven't moved on you know the brianna
taylor's killers are still uh
still walking free and um there's still
people in in louisville who've been
protesting every single day
for months getting arrested and and not
relenting and so
you know i think sometimes what happens
too is that for especially with you know
white people if it's not immediately in
your feed
and in your immediate in front of your
face in your feed
and you think oh it's not it doesn't
exist anymore so i think
uh you know the the level at which we
saw the pun of protests happening
all over all the time constantly um
that's still happening in a lot of
places
um it just might not be showing up in
your feet so um you know be sure to be
diversifying your feet and paying
attention to it
because it's all still happening but i
think you're right that there is a path
that's open and
this is a time for people to really be
thinking critically about how do you
stay on that path now it doesn't mean
that everything you do now has to be
completely
uh you know all about racial justice
unless that's the work that you really
want to be doing
i've been watching everybody you've had
on and you've had great people on that i
love
and you've had some incredible
conversations with your black guests
that you've had on
well what happens when will ferrell
comes on
i love will you know what does it look
like when in addition to his new movie
you also say hey like how are you
feeling about you know
the changes in society what how did
how'd the killing of george floyd
affect you you know will or pablo or
whatever
person's on um and that's where there's
like a real
that's unexpected and i think that's
where the me the needle starts to get
moved you know and it's
goes back to that idea about discomfort
like that's why people do not
expect to be asked about race
because we don't see ourselves as part
of race we often see
racism as something that happens to
other people
who do not look like us and we didn't do
it right but we are actually totally
complicit and
diplomacy uh impacts us all negatively
so
no i i think that's a really good point
i think
it's what's interesting about it is
the concept that when you're
when you're talking to people and this
is something i honestly don't know the
answer
but where i'm talking to people in
entertainment about their project
is then figuring out a way to do it
which
doesn't look like a gotcha doesn't look
like
um i've you know uh
and also asking them they may have very
visceral strong feelings about it and
they may not be prepared to talk about
that
so there needs to be a way to figure out
how can i
how can that be part of the conversation
ongoing
without it looking like i'm trying to
make people uncomfortable
do you know what i mean yeah but you
always are kind of making people
uncomfortable
you know that's just my appearance
[Laughter]
i can't do anything about that no i
can't believe we've been having to look
at this for so long
the thin lips and the eyes and uh yeah
no but i i agree that um
that there needs to be many different
ways
like one of the approaches that i've
wanted to take
is how can i not even so much as a
person with whatever kind of platform i
have
i'm always wary of my platform because i
think
my and i think i should be wary of my
platform because i
i'm not even comfortable with the word i
i feel like i'm someone who
has some ability at being silly and that
has
brought me into people's homes for a
long period of time and so i'm wary of
leaning against it
like the most important thing to me has
been how do i personally
how do i evolve how do i change the
culture that's
my ecosystem around me how can i improve
it how can i make
changes that and and sort of lead by
example does that make sense
it makes perfect sense you know taking
inventory of of
who's working for you you know by the
way everybody you work with that i've
interacted with
so far has been the nicest people ever
so good job
love them all um i've i've tried to fire
them but they have legal protections
which infuriates me you know labor
movement
what i really want what i really want is
a staff of [ __ ] but i legally don't
know how to
how to pull it off i don't know how to
do it um
i'm sure you could find a lawyer who
could help you figure that one out um no
i think that you know like whether it's
looking around at who are you employing
who are you working with who you're
hiring what does your writing room look
like
you know who are you bringing in what
does it like to be intentional about
that
you know but um but i wanted to say to
the idea of how do you bring up those
conversations in ways that don't feel
like a gotcha
you know again i think black
entertainers have been
there that's what they do i watched the
wonderful nicole buyer when you had her
on she's hilarious
and she talked both about the pain and
the challenge of this moment
and she also talked about her amazing
new book you know
what's uh uh great
is when i i love so many people are we
have a writer on our staff lori
kilmartin who's very good
at talking about she just lost her
mother to covid
and she was able to take that pain and
and
and braid it intertw entwine it with
humor in this way that was like a
razor's edge
and i think uh chris redd from starnet
live was on
and he was um you know
he's he can be so funny where he's
walking the razor's edge of
he can bring up being afraid of hearing
someone be racist when he's playing
a video game and they don't know who he
is and maybe someone's gonna you know
shout out the n-word uh and and not know
that he's
there but he was very funny talking
about that in a way that
it's such a powerful weapon to be funny
and bring up the biggest nuclear bomb
issue in american history for the last
250 years
and somehow combine the two those i mean
it's
so many entertainers are so good at
doing that
um and i think that's a very powerful
tool as well
and i think that's you know that's what
i always loved about kamau and his work
is how he does you know yeah
comedy is an incredibly powerful tool
and uh you can
you know you can do so much you can go
places and have conversations that
people
ordinarily would be too afraid to go to
um conan i wanted to ask you a question
um i'd love to hear what you've been
learning uh you know you wrote me a
wonderful email and really laid out a
lot of things you've been thinking about
so i'd love for you to tell the class
um
[Laughter]
well i got stoned i didn't write the
paper
[Laughter]
then i wrote something but my dog ate it
and uh
yeah no um what
i mean we talked a little bit about it
but one of the things is
you there's a i love to read so the
first thing
that i did and i didn't want it to feel
like i'm doing a good job and doing my
assignment i really wanted it to feel
like i want to do this for me
you know i want to so um
[Music]
one of the first things i read and i was
ashamed that i hadn't read it before
because it's a book that's been around
my
whole life is the autobiography of
malcolm x
and um it is one of the most harrowing
stories
personal stories that you're ever going
to read uh it's
it is a and it takes place in roxbury
which is right near where i grew up
and obviously uh malcolm x is growing up
uh in the 1940s
and 50s in roxbury and then moving to
harlem
but that transformation is absolutely
incredible and you can't
read that book and not see that this
person
uh i think his his father dies violently
uh at the hands of racists and his whole
life
is all about the color of his skin and
it completely and he's obviously
incredibly intelligent and incredibly
talented and incredibly good-looking and
charismatic
and it's you see how his entire life
is is changed by
uh institutional racism and
you i completely understand his point of
view by the time you get
to 1960 61 and he's 62 and he's saying
look i'm i respect dr martin luther king
and peaceful protests and everything but
you you understand how we got to
any means necessary you completely
understand it so
there's things as simple as uh
reading a book there's also tons of
conversations you can be having
and there are ways that you can think
about how
can i take my little world and make
changes
in it that will
for me and for the people around me uh
advance advance this movement
a little bit and so the question is
and and it's we've had a lot of talks
about it with my producer and with
people on the show just talking about
you know what can we do what can we do
in the makeup of our show what can we do
in uh and talking not just with the show
but
my wife and my kids what can we be doing
day in and day out
and one of the nice things is if my kids
are any example
one is 16 my daughter's 16 and my son's
14.
they're absolutely um
it's a generation and and their friends
as well
they're very very interested in making
this world
better and ra and racially fairer than
than it has been they're very i mean
it's not the top of their list
and so that's inspiring that's hopeful
now uh i did send your family shirts
that match the one i'm wearing um
did the kids get the black lives matter
uh care package
yes they did and i got your black lives
matter shirt as well
um and uh you know i
and this leads me to my next question
which is
i don't have a confusion about this i
want to make that clear
but there has been a common refrain
uh among certain people in this country
let's say black lives matter well all
lives matter
and i have a point of view about that
very strong point of view about that but
why don't you tell us
what you see the distinction being um
yeah that's that's just not something
that i
debate you know right that's just not a
debate um
and you know i think the way that i i
actually
i do touch on that here in this book i
wrote
look you have your own book with you
right there it's a super coincidence um
i didn't even realize it was right here
this is so lucky i'm i'm sorry um
uh and actually in this book again which
is an a to z book of radical
moments and movements from american
history many of which we don't learn
about in schools um
b is for black lives matter um it's
about the three women who founded the
movement
um and i actually addressed that so i'm
just going to read
my paragraph about that all right i say
some non-black people feel threatened or
left out by the phrase black lives
matter
what about us they've argued why single
out black lives
don't all lives matter the answer is yes
of course every human life matters but
until all humans are
actually treated equally in this country
it is justified
and vital to bring attention to certain
groups who've been routinely
statistically and historically harmed
that is my succinct uh kind of succinct
explanation what's not it's very good i
just was sending if
a sense memory no one's read to me uh
since i was about five
and it was and it was fantastic and i
missed over you started to nap no no no
no much
no they didn't glaze over but uh much
better content than the stuff they were
reading me when i was five
yeah i could we could do this i could i
could zoom with you at night and read
all these stories
what if my wife my wife's going to walk
in and go who's that woman
that you're talking to me at three
o'clock in the morning
and i'll be like no no we're talking
about race and she'll say yeah okay
i want a divorce well you know it's
i will say one thing i found in in
writing these books because the books
that i write with my collaborator miriam
kleinstall
um they're aimed at young readers um but
i do a lot of school visits while in
in the before times i would go into
classrooms a lot um
and i always love to read to young
people but i love reading to high school
students and college students and i'll
read to adults we all really like to be
read too so
um so yeah that's that's that's my
answer um
but i had the same feeling which is uh i
mean immediately which is
the reason uh the state the statement
black lives matter comes
out of this
uh incredibly undeniable this incredible
undeniable history of neglect
that's why the statement needs to be
made yeah in the first
so so then to say look wait a minute no
all lives matter is to deny that we have
an issue
we have a specific racial issue in this
country yeah
and at this point also you know at this
point
in the conversation in the movement in
our country
at this point to say all lives matter
that is an expressly
violent and racist statement at this
point and we're beyond context
in fact here where i live i live in
alameda california right next to oakland
um several black families in town
recently woke up to find their cars
vandalized their tires had been slashed
they'd been keyed
and all lives matter and alm had been
spray painted all over the cars this is
in the
the liberal bay area so that's it's it
we're beyond the conversation of
of debating whether black weather the
phrases
yeah and and you know black lives matter
and again i talk about it in the book
it that phrase began with conversations
amongst three black women who were
friends who were
feeling unbelievable rage
and sorrow when george zimmerman was
acquitted of the murder of trayvon
martin
and they literally just typed on
facebook i feel like black lives don't
matter
and then they turned that in and said
you know what black lives do matter
black lives matter and they started that
as a hashtag initially to
to share love and to uplift their
community uh and then as it caught on
they were like wow
this maybe is a movement and then
they've built it into a global movement
and
um those women are alicia garza opal
tonight and patrice colors
and they have been propelling this um
you know
and it's uh it's it's an important
phrase we put it on the cover of the
book too
um and uh and i do one of the things
when i first started doing these
instagram lives after i received my
promotion to um
being in charge of your whiteness uh
trust me it's a demotion
well i have i wasn't working a lot
because of quarantine so i
i was i had some time take the jobs that
come your way
so but one of the first things i talked
to people about was you know if you're
wondering what to do right now
as you're grappling with what can i do
what do i read which book
get a piece of paper write black lives
matter on it and tape it up in your
window
you know and if you can't take that step
if you're a white person and you're not
ready to do that to make your support
visible
then there's a lot more kind of deep
work that you have to do and and that
could maybe show you what you need to do
but if you could do that
um it actually it does have an impact
i've been hearing a lot of really
powerful stories of
of how that that show of solidarity and
support
um has had so much meaning to so many
people
um the last thing i wanted to bring up
was
something that all of us are grappling
with right now
talking to someone uh who doesn't agree
with you
wanting to change
their perception maybe convince them
and it feels like we're in a place in
our country
where someone's with you or they're not
someone's in
your group or they're in the other group
and
i'm just saying this as a i'm i'm i'm
trying to address everybody with this
if you're a rabid trump supporter uh
or if you think he's the antichrist
how can we get to a place where we can
talk about these things
you can't shout someone down and yell at
them and intimidate them into agreeing
with you
uh about some of these issues so what do
you do
yeah it's the uh it's the it's the
age-old question
um i think you make you make
strategic smart choices that
conserve your energy and protect your
humanity
and and also are
good uses of your energy right um and so
i think that sometimes i will say that
i've never
ever ever seen an argument be one in a
facebook thread
no have you ever seen it happen i've
never seen online
anyone go you know what i've been
thinking about it
and you're right ufos don't exist
so i think there can be when you really
believe something and you're seeing
not stuff online it's very tempting to
get into it i
at this point in my world i don't do
that your hair looks great by the way
it's incredible
you know i think that should be the most
important thing everyone takes away from
this conversation
it is it is conan's hair and then race
relations in america
i have my priorities straight yeah you
know maybe you could like
we could like spray paint black lives
matter onto your hair then it could just
be always there
right okay all right we can do that
sort of an orange sometimes i found for
people who have family members
um especially maybe older generation
family members who they're
they want to be able to connect with
over this but it's hard sometimes
connecting through history
um through like historical events can be
a kind of way in um to get to those
conversations
and i also think that we have to accept
that we're just not gonna change
everybody's mind
um and i don't think i don't there's
people who disagree with me i do not
think that you
that we are under that we are obligated
to get into
long drawn-out conversations with people
who don't respect the basic humanity
of the people that we love you know um
and that said i think that if you do see
someone online
who you know and you you want to engage
with them or
or it's a family member asking people if
they're willing to talk to you offline
you know hey i have a different opinion
and i'd
be really interested in sharing about
like what i believe would you ever be
willing to talk to me
you know privately or on the phone you
know um
and and if you can come i mean i think
that for people who are interested in
having those conversations
learning the basics of non-violent
communication is incredibly helpful
because i agree with you
you're not going to shout people you
know and it can go from zero to like 10
million
so quickly because people get so upset
absolutely right especially right now i
mean
it's always been that way but right now
it feels definitely like a powder keg
and we're seeing every day we talked
about this before on social media
people have even taken wearing masks
face masks
as a basic protection they've
somehow made that an issue that they've
tied to
uh you know um race or
uh uh income wealth they've tied it to
all this other st
freedom uh government versus no
government
and it's like no no just put on a mask
it's really simple just put on a
mask but no that's what we've
we've if if people are losing it over
wearing a piece of paper over their
mouth for the 10 minutes that they're at
a costco
we see what's gonna happen when you're
implying that they're
part of a racist system that needs to be
uh
that needs to be fixed they're gonna
really lose it
that's where you choose your battles
right that's where you choose is this
going to be worth the energy that it's
going to take me
and could i use my energy elsewhere i'll
tell you that you know a lot of people
that i talk to who have struggled with
really racist family members
you the aunt and uncle grandma grandpa
the parents they may be far gone but
those nieces and nephews those little
cousins you know
right send them my books you know have
those conversations like you said about
your kids like they're
a different generation so sometimes i
think maybe it's if you're the aunt
connecting with that niece or nephew um
in a way that doesn't like
you know the parents but uh i don't talk
to any of my relatives that's how i take
care of it
that's all my manager talks to everyone
for me you know
he tells me they're lovely people
the other thing i'd say is sometimes i
think about
talking to people who don't get it or
who you disagree with
you know it's almost like talking to my
almost seven-year-old
son where i have to remind myself that
we're gonna have a lot of conversations
where
what i say in the moment may not seem to
change anything with him
but it's going to sink in over time
right i think that it's still worth
doing your best to share resources
recommend books recommend documentaries
maybe
the back and forth on facebook isn't
going to change anything but like
maybe you can get that aunt to listen to
the 1619 podcast you know
or to watch when they see us or to watch
13th
you know maybe just putting those
resources out there
um maybe that can work with someone over
time and they might not change their
mind in the moment that you're in the
conversation
but stuff could sink in that's how i
feel about parenting basically at all
times
right well uh i appreciate this
conversation
a lot i like to be an optimist and i
i uh i like to know that good people are
out there
trying to do good work and so i'm uh
wait i have one more question i know
we're
done but uh i am curious to know like
what is one thing that you learned from
my book that you
were like fascinated to learn as a
history buff that you didn't know before
well i'm going to say maya lynn what i
didn't know was that maya lin was in
college when she designed the vietnam
memorial and that she got
that much opposition to it and that she
fought back
what college student who was told yes
we're going to build your monument we
just need you to make a few changes says
i don't think so it's good the way it is
and then it turned out to be such a
stunning success
that's one of the coolest uh i mean the
books
the books filled with very amazing
stories that was the one that stuck with
me because i was so
shocked that someone that young
um it just had the guts and temerity and
vision
and then saw it all the way through and
then it turned into a massive success in
her lifetime
immediately not like man not like van
gogh like where okay
maybe he's a ghost somewhere and he's
appreciating that his stuff is making a
lot of money
he's a one-eared ghost but uh yeah
i i really love that excellent van ghost
van ghost exactly all right i'll do the
comedy here
all right thank you very much uh and uh
as i said kate's book is called rad
american history a to z
it's available now and uh kate chops
thank you very much for doing this
thank you conan you're doing a good job
and very proud of you
you